possessed preteen Reagan McNeil goes
through hell over the course of the 1973
classic The Exorcist and the most
hellish moment is probably when she
projectile vomit split pea soup onto
father Keras naturally enough he reacts
by gasping for breath and looking
appropriately disgusted but if you look
really closely you can also detect a
hint of uncharacteristic anger on the
usually even-tempered priest this is
because Jason Miller the actor who
played him was include into what exactly
was going to happen in the BBC
documentary the fear of God 25 years of
The Exorcist the movie's head of special
effects revealed that he was all set up
to have the vomits hit Miller in the
chest as scripted and rehearsed but
delays in setting up the scene led to
the vomit getting cold so the trajectory
of the reg was changed and tilted it up
towards Miller's face and his unscripted
reaction made it into the Final Cut